Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Super toretisch!
gleich und dann habe ich pepo fett eingeblendet und dann habe ich festgestellt ich bin wirklich
gemutet und es hat mich echt keiner gehört weil spätestens darauf hat der chat reagiert
so und wisst ihr warum ich platze leute nicht weil ich so fett bin sondern weil mir juckt es so
extrem in den fingern ich habe es gestern auf twitter geschrieben mir juckt es so extrem in
den fingern mir endlich wieder einen neuen rechner zu kaufen ich meine wann gab es das denn guckt
mal hier mein aktueller rechner der ist drei jahre ziemlich genau runden wir mal auf oktober
der ist ziemlich genau drei jahre alt wie kann es sein dass ein drei jahre alter rechner immer noch
zum oberen ende gehört also ich weiß das ist jetzt die absolute boomer geschichte aber umgedreht
aber umgedreht boomer weil ich früher war da war der kram viel schneller kaputt das hält übelst lang
der kram was ist da los mittlerweile kommen öfters konsolen raus als du dir neuen pc kaufen musst
das kann doch nicht sein oder wie geht das sowas naja zumindest mir juckt es echt in den fingern
was neues zu kaufen die sache ist die ich kann mir nichts neues kaufen das lohnt sich einfach
überhaupt nicht ich mein guckt mal ich habe mir den ok das ding war auch absolut top 2017
nach 1700 keine 1080 t uns es gab nicht viel besseres das es gab es gab ja quasi nichts
viel besseres zum damaligen zeitpunkt ich hatte eine der ersten 8700 k in deutschland also das
ist jetzt nicht so als werde schlecht aber trotzdem wenn ich mich wenn ich mir zurückdenke zu zeiten
wo man noch schwanzvergleich mit towergröße gemacht hat so zu zeiten wo sagen wir mal
farkrall 1 aktuell war und solche geschichten hast du den rechner gekauft und der war zwei
jahre später nicht einfach nur schlecht der war der war wie sagen wie sagen sie den englischen
dog shit der war übelster shit der war übelster crap nach zwei jahren konntest du den rechner
quasi im hohen bogen vor dem fenster in den müll schmeißen ob er dabei geputt gegangen ist
vollkommen egal und jetzt habe ich mir einen high end rechner gekauft und das ding ist nach drei
jahren ich will vielleicht nicht sagen immer noch absolut high end aber immer noch am obersten ende
ja klar du kannst ein bisschen schnellere cpu haben du kannst ein bisschen schnellere grafikkarte
haben aber dass es bewegt sich alles so im bereich 10 15 prozent wenn es hochkommt ja eine cpu in
spielen und in so normalen anwendung schneller als nach 1700k übertaktet auf 5 5,1 gigahertz da
ist nix selbst die neueste intel cpu ist nicht schneller also in spielen amd ähnlich so und
deswegen mir juckt es so krass in den fingern den rechner zu kaufen und ich weiß schon genau was
ich mir kauf ich habe es ja ich habe es ja gestern irgendwann mal auf twitter auf twitter sogar
geschrieben ich weiß genau was ich mir kauf ich habe schon ich habe schon quasi die die einkaufs
liste habe ich schon vor mir ja aber aber es kommt nichts raus also sobald sobald was neues
rauskommt werde ich mir als erstes erstes kommt mir hier einen fractal define define 7 neues
gehäuse kommt anstatt mit glasplatte weil ich hatte jetzt schon ein fractal design f4 f5 f6
und jetzt kommt der sieben er keinen das jetzt das haben das eher weggelassen zeig mal deine
hardware ist da gibt es nicht sonderlich viel zu zeigen 8700k 1080 ti referenz design 32g ram
das ist ja nichts dolles und eine m2 ssd so und das ding hol ich mir als kreuz ist frisch
rausgekommen dann gibt es den reisen 4950 x also wenn es den denn mal gibt das ist dann
wahrscheinlich 16 kerner 4950 x vielleicht auch in 4970 x wobei eigentlich total sinnlos aber
16 kerne ist schon nice eine 3080 ti aber es kommt ja nix die kriegen es nicht gebacken die
kriegen es diesmal ich bin hier kurz vorm platzen und will geld ausgeben ja aber ich darf mein
geld nicht ausgeben das ist das schlechteste was du als hersteller machen kannst wenn die
leute ihr geld ausgeben wollen und sie können dir ihr geld nicht geben ich will ich will ich will
euch mein geld geben aber ich kann euch mein geld nicht geben das ist doch was was kein hersteller
will oder das ist doch das kann sein also meine hardware liste falls das irgendjemand interessiert
hier 8700k noch turlüfter 32 32 sind es mittlerweile 32 g ram irgendein komisches xx hd headshot pro 360
tolles mainboard m2 ssd freckle diese oh sorry ich habe miss erzählt kein f5 ist es r6 hatte ich
gar nicht be quiet und 8000 1080 couch excellent couch und warum ist so was ich gebe sogar ein
geiz als linker warum ist so was nach nach nach drei jahren immer noch high end ich ver- ich
verstehe es nicht so so und genau das wie gesagt genau das werde ich mir kaufen sobald nein hier
ist nicht der max also doch schon hier aber nicht nicht da jetzt also wie gesagt das gehäuser
freut mich schon drauf dass es logisches upgrade von dem was ich jetzt hab und irgendwie ich das
geht mir das geht mir voll voll auf den keks na wolltest du nicht vor einiger zeit den reisen
kauf doch weil mir schon seit letztem jahr in den finger juck neues system zusammenzubauen aber es
ist total bescheuert den reisen zu bauen jetzt so wie es ist wenn ich mir den reisen 3950 3950 x
kaufe dann ist der gar nicht mal schneller als meiner jetzt er hat einfach nur mehr kerne das
ist ja nice to have aber wenn schon dann will ich auch in normalen anwendungen bisschen mehr
leistung haben wenn ich der witz ist ja wenn ich mir jetzt wenn ich mir jetzt einen rechner kauf
mit einem reisen 3950 x da habe ich mehr kerne aber ich bin in spielen sogar langsamer als mein
drei jahre alte 8700 kader bisschen übertaktet das so das heißt wenn ich wenn ich aufrüste
dann will ich nicht so ein bisschen aufrüsten so von zwischen zwischen null und zehn maximal
15 prozent sondern das ding sollte schon immer 20 30 prozent schneller sein so reisen kann man
nicht gescheit oder der boostet sich ja selbst schon ganz gut so und das ist einfach mist und ich will
ihnen meine kohle geben aber ich kann ihnen meine kennst du kreativ ich habe irgendwas glaube ich
auf twitter von so jemand gelesen also hieß ja so und die sache ist die sollten sie es jetzt schaffen
mal bis ende des jahres ist ja nicht mehr so lang ich meine wir haben schon Mitte august
4.950 x und 30 80 ti rauszubringen habe ich mir das schon genau überlegt kupfer mal neun
monat dankeschön excellent subscription dann wird das ganze wahrscheinlich ungefähr so sein 1000
euro grafikkarte 1000 euro gpu so wie cpu ein bisschen weniger grafikkarte wahrscheinlich
bisschen mehr bei release also sagen was über daumen gepeilt 1000 euro grafikkarte 1000 euro cpu
und 1000 euro für den rest das heißt da kann ich endlich wieder ich warte schon drauf ich bin schon
so heiß drauf endlich mal neue hardware zusammenschrauben der rest der rest wird so
dass die üblichen verdächtigen in be quiet netz teil meine 10 gigabit netzwerkarte kommt
rein in fetter noch turlüfter kommt wieder rein mit mit chrome x weil weil weil auch immer hat
ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn warum man seinen lüfter irgendwie planten drauf machen sollte weil
da guckt man eh nicht rein ergibt eigentlich wenig wenig sinn aber warum nicht ja rgb ram rgb
ram natürlich rgb ram und für mehr fps ich nehme den gleichen ram den ich jetzt hab bloß
ein bisschen schnellere variante davon so und ich hoffe dass es bis dahin endlich eine 4 terabyte
samsung m2 ssd gibt die gibt es nämlich noch nicht das maximale was samsung aktuell hat
ich glaube 2 terabyte ja und und ich hoffe die hat die schaffen es bis ende des jahres eine
vier terabyte zu haben warum brauchst du so viel weil ich es haben will also kann man nie
genug ssd speicher haben das ist ja schon mal klar also wenn man eins nicht haben kann da ist es
genug ssd speicher genau um sachen zu speichern 2 mal 2 terabyte da müsste ich ja irgendwelche
entweder irgendwelche rate geschichten machen die ich garantiert mit windows nicht machen oder
irgendwelche die zusammen bandeln oder eben beides als unterschiedliche festplatten verwenden also
liebe aufteilen damit nicht alles auf einer auf der ich kauf mir eine 4 terabyte ssd dass gerade
alles auf einer ist warum soll ich das aufteilen wozu immer immer drauf dann lässt sich auch viel
einfacher backup machen einfach hier flupp komprimiert die duplication fertig mit ein paar
verzeichnungen ex excluded aber wenn es das bis ende des jahres nicht gibt dann dann hole ich
mir halt eine 2 terabyte ssd meinetwegen übrigens ich glaube dass mit 3000 euro wird knapp wenn
ich mir überlege was kosten was kosten so eine aktuelle 4 terabyte samsung das wird knapp das
wird ganz schön knapp 1000 euro cpu 1000 euro gpu dann bleibt ja 500 euro ok sagen wir mal die
m2 sagen wir mal die m2 die m2 kosten wahrscheinlich sogar eher 600 euro da bleiben noch 400 euro
übrig für gehäuse mainboard und das reicht nicht mehr das reicht nicht mehr das reicht nicht
ganz es wird ein bisschen teurer wahrscheinlich weil da bleiben da bleiben noch 400 euro übrig
für netzteil lüfter rgb ram gehäuse das reicht nicht das reicht nicht warte mal geizhals was
habe ich aktuell für für den ram den will ich wieder haben ich will den gleichen ram den ich
jetzt habe nur ein bisschen schneller ich habe dings hier guck da hier ja exzellent
reisen reisen mark schnellen ram sowas hier so und das ganze dann mal vier ach du scheiße
ok das wird das wird doch ein bisschen teurer als 3000 so 3500 hast du gesehen das ist grad
recht günstig ein terabyte pc ssd es gibt nö wo aber wozu du meinst so eine hier keine keine
wirklich für pc also wie gesagt ich kaufe mir den gleichen ram nur bisschen schneller brauche
dampf so das ist das problem warum ich kurz vor platzen bin und ich war halt kurz davor zu
dieser thematik schon youtube video aufzunehmen weil ich gesagt habe es kann nicht sein es kann
nicht sein dass ich seit drei jahren hardware am start habe nichts daran ändere und es beim
kauf absolut highend war und jetzt immer noch oberes segment ist nach drei jahren ich krieg
es nicht was preise singen flotte ssd selig okay zeig ja das ist doch gut dann gibt es
dann vielleicht bis wenn die das jetzt ablösen dann gibt es dann vielleicht bis ende des
jahres eine vier terabyte m2 was machst du mit der alten hardware wahrscheinlich das
gleiche was ich mit der hardware davor gemacht habe die rechner einfach austauschen also
sprich ich habe hier zwei rechner nebeneinander stehen den aktuellen und den von davor und
der eine ist vorschau für stream und und mit dem zweiten monitor dran vorschau für stream
und ein paar kleinigkeiten und das andere ist halt hauptrechner und den werde ich einfach
austauschen und vielleicht mit dem noch älteren also der ist ja auch nicht schlecht ist auch
in vier kerne denkst du davor da mache ich mir vielleicht in linux kiste zu ein bisschen
rumbasteln auch im stream so sieht es aus ok aber so viel zu meinen hardware fantasien
was ich da kaufen will was ich nicht kommen will kommen wir mal zum zum thema 3d drucker
nämlich die eigentliche sache übrigens ich mache mal mein das funk das funktioniert
übrigens mittlerweile ich weiß ich ob es auf twitter gesehen habe wenn ich auf twitter
am start ist aber wer gerne die streams guckt das kann ich euch sagen das lohnt sich insofern
weil ich immer mal aktuelle sachen zu themen poste die wir auch gerade uns im stream angucken
hier da ist das das fertige das fertige projekt klimaanlagensteuerung das ist das was wir
hier was wir hier im stream angefangen haben das hier ist ein esp 32 mit einem display
also hatte ich noch den hatte ich noch das ist eigentlich laura board deswegen die antenne
laura brauche ich nicht aber das display drauf das war in dem fall ganz praktisch das da
hinten ist der temperatur sensor temperatur luftfeuchtigkeit sensor das ist die aktuelle
luftfeuchtigkeit aktuelle temperatur und der keks hält die infrarot led die zur klimaanlage
zeigt dass das die klimaanlage steuern kann so und ich habe da noch den knopf hier oben
programmiert dass ich damit die klimaanlage eine ausschalten kann und dann und das ist
übrigens der grund warum ich heute anfange mit 3d drucker das war der eigentliche grund
warum ich heute angefangen habe mit 3d drucker weil ich nach schönen gehäusen für dieses
teil hier gesucht habe und da ist mir aufgefallen auf fack mein 3d drucker geht ja gerade gar
nicht ja was kostet so ein sensor du meinst hier so luftholp 350 bei aliexpress oder so
oh sorry sorry eins 168 ich bin ich bin ich von china preisen ausgegangen 168 von wegen
fünf euro ok guck mal wenn du neu bist musst du gar nichts dafür bezahlen da kannst du
hier infinite money loup machen kriegst du krieg guck mal du kriegst ein 70 erstattet
von den ein 70 machst du dir neuen account und kaufst wieder in sowas so ein sensor dann
kriegst du es wieder erstattet und dann du kaufst dir wieder ein sensor und dann kriegst
du es wieder erstattet davon kaufst die nächsten also oder hast du in infinite money loup easy
money ja aber aliexpress da kram ist wirklich billig so genau das war eigentlich auch der
stein des anstoßes hier dass ich ja versandt genau zum thema versandt muss ich muss ich
noch was sagen ich muss bei irgendwo in sensor aufwachen den ich auch bestellen darf als
neu als neukunde versandt muss ich sagen ich würde mir eh nie einen bestellen nie ein
also der versandt aus china ist eh billiger als der versandt aus deutschland das ist ja
eh schon irgendwie ein bisschen lächerlich aber es ist halt so wahrscheinlich subventionieren
wir das irgendwie und die chinesen auch noch und zumindest deswegen würde ich immer so
10er pack dann eben klar so braucht man immer mal 10er pack dann bezahlste kannst du hier
noch ausgucken aber am besten das ist schon das schon ganz gutes ganz gutes shipping das
ist sogar relativ schnell das braucht ungefähr einen monat meistens ist es schneller so dann
bist du am ende bei 16 euro 2 euro versand 18 euro und du bezahlst für einen sensor hier
schon du bezahlst für einen sensor ne ne ne das ist schwachsinn achso das sind 3 stück
ja 14 durch 3 exzellent 4,6 also viel zu teuer in deutschland der kram guck mal da ist es
ja china china kram also und das ist auch der anstoß gewesen warum ich mit 3d drucker
kram angefangen habe ja aber jetzt mal zum thema 3d drucker jo was geht ja wir haben
noch nicht großartig gerade nicht viel wir haben gerade noch nicht so großartig angefangen
so sind 3d drucker immer noch so teuer ne es geht ich bin jetzt aktuell nicht mehr ganz
so drinnen was das thema der 3d drucker angeht weil ich habe mir den gekauft bin damit jetzt
eigentlich ganz zufrieden der hier ist relativ günstig der war damals auch schon relativ
günstig aber davon gibt es glaube ich einen neuen was aktuell relativ angesagt ist bei
3d drucker ist ein fack wie ist das ding seit seit war ein da x1 war das der der ist aktuell
relativ angesagt das habe ich in in einem 3d drucker form gelesen keine ahnung ob das
wirklich stimmt also ich kann da keine empfehlung aussprechen aber der ist aktuell auch noch
relativ angesagt dann ganz einsteiger mäßig ist das ding das ist auch relativ beliebt
das ist noch mal noch mal eine ganze ecke billiger das geht so 150 euro los und wer
was richtig cooles haben will da war ich damals auch kurz davor mir einzukaufen aber ich wollte
nicht 1000 euro ausgeben war ich weiß gar nicht mehr welches war von dem ich glaube der
glaub der bin jetzt aber nicht ganz sicher ich also wenn es wenn es der war dann ist
der richtig gut der hat aber sagt man so bei 3d drucker macht es der preis schon ein bisschen
aus also vor allem halt auch was komfortfunktionen angeht zum beispiel bei dem bei meinem habe ich
das alles mit vorsicht zu genießen ich bin nicht der wahnsinnig 3d drucker profi bei
meinem ist es so der hier das druckbett kann die auflösung hochgehen das druckbett wenn
das schräg ist und das werden wir auch gleich mal ausprobieren dass das hier unten so schrauben
das musst du selbst einstellen und muss selbst kalibrieren so und wenn du hier so ein prusa
wie auch immer man das genau ausspricht holst der hat zum beispiel sensoren die vorher checken wie
dein druckbett ausgerichtet ist und kalibriert sich selbst also du hast bei 3d drucker der preis
macht da viele komfortfunktionen aus hier soll wohl die firme auch richtig gut sein der support
auch richtig gut sein und generell die qualität von dem ding richtig gut sein das ist sowohl
ist vor einer weile mal so als geheimtipp gestartet mittlerweile dürfte das eine der
beliebtesten 3d drucker überhaupt sein ja das und das war sich aktuell grad zum thema 3d
musik geht mir voll auf den sack gut also kommen wir zum thema 3d drucker die sache ist die wenn man
also denn wie gesagt den habe ich entweder entweder anfang 2019 oder oder 2018 muss ich mal kurz so ich
poste doch alles mögliche auf twitter ich poste doch alles mögliche auf twitter twitter ist so lebe
lebenshistorie was ist das denn was doch gar nicht twitter ach so das war auf der games com
hat jemand guten tipp für den eintrag ok dann habe ich mir anfangen 2019 gekauft den 3d drucker
wenn ich hier nach einem guten einsteigen dann habe ich mir das glaube ich am gleichen tag
noch bestellt any cubic ja also irgendwie also ich habe dir ungefähr ein ja das ding und ich
habe damit halt nicht so viel gedruckt ich habe mir das hauptsächlich gekauft um gehäuse zu
drucken für meinen bastel kram hast du den i3 schon auch schon umgebaut was meinst du genau also
was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe ein i3 mega s das ist ja schon die etwas neuere variante
was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe eigentlich nur eine kamerahalterung dran gemacht und einen
led ring an den lüfter stromanschluss dass das ding schön beleuchtet ist wenn er druckt ansonsten
also ich habe weder den motor umgebaut noch habe ich irgendwelche treibergeschichten umgebaut noch
habe ich irgendwelche firmenflash geschichten gemacht oder so gar nichts ich wollte jetzt
eigentlich auch gar nicht so viel basteln sondern bloß ab und zu mal in gehäuse drucken ja so und
was wir heute machen ist folgendes einfach so ein 3d drucker leute ich muss andere musik an
machen das das nervt mich hier das ist zu zu aufdringlich irgendwie die kamera die ist hier
oben dran also ich habe zwei varianten für die kamera aktuell habe ich sie hier oben dran die
guckt von oben auf das druckband und ich habe mir eine halterung ausgedruckt dass man die kamera
hier vorne dran stecken kann das eigentlich auch ganz cool geht das kann ich mir jetzt schon eher
geben bis sie lauter und ich will ihr entscheiden ok das bisschen doof bei 3d drucker ist es gibt
welche die haben den eingebauten webserver und so da ist das alles nicht nicht so wild aber bei
den meisten 3d drucker ist es halt so du kannst die drucke dort nur per sd karte dran machen oder
mit einem laptop am usb das ist alles ein bisschen doof so und deswegen gibt es dieses projekt hier
octo print würdest du dir den 3d drucker nochmal kaufen ja ich finde den preisleistung also
preisleistungsmäßig ist das ding wirklich top ich kann dir allerdings nicht sagen ob das noch das
aktuelle modell ist wir können mal gucken ob die noch ob die noch was neueres mittlerweile haben in der richtung
da kommt man scheint gibt es ein mega x ein mega pro mega s ok da ist wohl immer noch halbwegs
aktuell der ist wahrscheinlich größer das hier ist glaube ich einfach ein s plus plus ein bisschen
größer vermute ich mal ja aber den würde ich wieder kaufen also chat ich weiß nicht wer von
euch damit auch erfahrung hat könnte ihm ja mal was zu schreiben aber ich finde den preisleistungsmäßig
wirklich gut gibt es auch ein monka es das wäre eigentlich mal richtig guter 3d drucker name
ja so also fangen wir an wie gesagt normalerweise muss man da per sd karte dran oder per usb und
es gibt ein schönes projekt das nennt sich octo print das kann man auf dem raspberry pi
installieren und dann kann man über den raspberry pi 3d drucke hochladen und drucken lassen und
und zustand gucken und webcam zum überprüfen es gibt richtig coole plugins habe ich gesehen
also ich habe hier den test letzte letzte mal wo ich octo print verwendet habe ich ganz
klassisch ohne jegliche plugins verwendet aber es sind mir ein paar sachen auf den keks gegangen
wo es wohl recht coole plugins gibt zum beispiel dass man eine anzeige auf dem 3d drucker display
hat wie lange es noch dauert dass man die druckzeit besser berechnen kann dass man das sidebar mit
der webcam hat dass man bessere timelapses machen kann dass man fail drucks erkennen kann und und
solche solche geschichten ja da gibt es da gibt es jede menge jede menge sachen sonst wollte ich
jetzt mal ausprobieren weil ich will mir wieder ein paar gehäuse drucken und nachdem ein aktueller
octo pie kaputt ist machen wir das ganze jetzt mal so dazu gehen wir jetzt nämlich mal auf
github gehen wir hier in die vm ganze tabs hier mal wieder zu also wieviel tabs haben wir hier
offen ich war mal den browser zu dass er ein bisschen rampfrei gibt man weiß ja nie
aber ja erst mal alles alles dicht 16 dare lul github octo pie
also wie gesagt es gibt octo print und es gibt octo pie das eine ist die software an sich die
man später verwendet octo pie ist nix anderes wie in den raspian image was einer schon fertig
gebaut hat was aber einfacher was die sache aber einfacher macht ja deswegen habe ich das
auch aus also ich mache ich habe keine fade animation viel besser wenn man so die desktops
umschalten kann man checker hintergrund diesmal übrigens für die für den hintergrund ist das
einzige was ich bei bing verwende ein bing aber bing hat einen schönen daily image algoritmus
jetzt laden wir uns den kram mal runter ich schnapp mir mal einen wo ist er denn micro sd karten leser
wo habe ich hier da ist einer oder brauchst du eine micro sd karte und dann flaschen wir das
ganze mal und das erste was wir machen werden ist die webcam einschalten dass ihr auch was
seht und ich auch was sehe und ich nicht laufen drüber rennen muss bingen war doch die porno
suchmaschine an ich bin zwar keine ahnung was da alles gibt glaube glaube da gibt es bessere sachen
als bing ich könnte ja mal im recording ordner gucken ob ich da eine suchmaschine finde das hat
jetzt keiner verstanden außer die dabei waren so also wir haben den kram jetzt runtergeladen
starten wir mal eine runde etcher flash vom feil downloads war mal den kram hier mal hin
hallo downloads octopi buster light moment hat er ist noch gar nicht fertig mit rund ich habe
war zu schnell wo davon kommt nicht mit du meinst in windows ja kann man das ausschalten wusste
ich gar nicht flash vom feil octopi light jetzt jetzt dürfen wir select target nein nein auf die
systemplatte will ich nicht flaschen jetzt aber select target 32 g samsung ssd select flash gut
hauen wir das mal auf die micro sd gerade drauf und wie gesagt sobald wir das drüben sobald
es drüben im raspberry pi reingesteckt habe werde ich die webcam als erstes anmachen da
gucken wir gleich mal ob man da gescheit was sie drinnen so so und plugins müssen wir gucken ich
habe mir ein paar ich habe mir ein paar sachen aufgeschrieben kann man so zum beispiel was ich
ganz praktisch fand war diese geschichte dass man seine webcam anders an der seite sieht dann
was auch noch richtig richtig gut ausgesehen hat ist hier print time print time genius sah
auch ziemlich praktisch aus dass man genauer berechnen kann wie die druckzeit ist was richtig
gut ist ist das wollte ich schon die ganze zeit mal die ganze zeit mal ausprobieren allerdings
weiß ich nicht ob das kostenlos ist aber die idee ist richtig gut und zwar der erkennt der erkennt
quasi per per k.i. na nicht k.i. das ist eine open vc geschichte der erkennt per algoritmus wenn
der 3d drucke anfängt miss zu trocken guckt hier was praktisch ist weil wenn der wenn der erkennt
dass der 3d drucke anfangen miss zu trocken sieht man es hier vielleicht sieht man es jetzt ja
nochmal dann bricht er nicht ab oder so sondern hält an das ist ziemlich praktisch weil wenn
sich das ding mal irrt kann man einfach drauf gucken und sagen moment mal mach weiter aber wenn
er wirklich fehlt ist wir jetzt hier auch meint dass das irgendwie gefällt gefällt hat dann
spart man einfach material weil der muss ja nicht weiter drucken wenn der druck hier voll am
abkacken ist twitterplug in dem ein 3d drucker muss nicht zwittern so
ich gehe dann klein so wohin wie machen das jetzt leute ich muss meine wlan konfig anpassen
ohne dass ihr es seht wie machen wir das jetzt also es ist nicht so schlimm ich habe einen extra
wlan für streams aber ich will euch das passwort trotzdem nicht verraten ich muss ich muss euch die
ich muss die kamera ausschalten so gut so jetzt haben wir die ganzen kram geflasht was wir jetzt
machen muss ist und das muss man übrigens bei jeder raspberry pi installation machen bzw raspberry
pi installation machen man muss sich die die boot partition mal mountain und dort wlan konfig anlegen
so war ich jetzt mal kurz mache ich mal kurz aus ich überlasse euch dem chat und ich trage
mal meine wlan daten ein ohne dass ihr die seht und dann hoffe ich dass ich mich verschreibe
weil das ist im clipboard manager drin ein easy ich mein passwort ich hab's aus so also mit
allem lasse ich mich auch daten ok jetzt muss man das land einstellen wir sind nicht franz wir
sind de so sehr schön fertig ich mache euch wieder an ich mache euch wieder an das immer so
habe ich meine wlan credentials eingegeben zynk unmount und jetzt gehe ich rüber und stöpsel
das ganze raspberry pi rein land liegt o mg gut dann dass ihr was zu tun habt ich bin in
keine ahnung eine minute wieder da ich muss bloß die sd karte rein stöpseln das ist ja also
ich habe den 3d trocker nicht hier stehen ich habe den 3d trocker drüben drüben in so einem
abstellraum stehen weil das geht immer voll auf den sack wenn das ding herum fährt und pustet
und macht ja ss hs am
also wieder am start jetzt gucken wir mal was das ding für eine ip gekriegt hat ich habe
geschaut was der alte hatte also der müsste eigentlich die hier bekommen der müsste eigentlich
die bekommen weil er hatte die alte hatte der hatte die ip zumindest aber mal schauen
nebenbei auf einem ah da ist er ok wunderbar muss mich da nicht auf einem router einloggen
so ssh pi add yes raspberry und einloggen please einloggen einloggen slowchamp was sind wir
perfekt hat funktioniert max was ist denn octopi das ist raspberry pi distribution eigentlich
ist ein raspian plus zusatzsoftware ist nichts großartiges eigenes für den 3d trocker wo man
3d trocker aufträge und so was besser mit managen kann auch nur webcam an 3d trocker machen und so
was so und jetzt sollen wir dass das da oben funk funktioniert garantiert nicht jetzt sollen
wir hier auf die adresse wir gehen mal hier im browser dahin und jetzt sollte da wenn wir
glück haben ein octopi aufgehen oder auch nicht wir kommen was das ding für eine auslastung hat ok
da ist noch ein bisschen beschäftigt da können wir bei der gelegenheit gerade mal die die wichtigsten
sachen überhaupt installieren den wim den wim den t-max und dies der hartop und dass ich einfach
neu starte hallo was macht dies der zeige ich dir gleich das ist ein das ist in dem pyson
programm wo man die auslastung vom rechner auch mäßig sich angucken kann ist finde ich
ganz praktisch da sieht man netzwerkverkehr und auf die platte und sowas ich machs mal kurz an so
was ihr guckt da siehst du hier rewrite platte cpu so net receive also eigentlich guckt man
das ist nur für die zwei sachen hier an völlig ist die übrigen fast über sich man es kann auch
ein bisschen mehr mit optionen ab so da sind wir exzellent hallo installing octopi wizard jawohl
exes control der pro exes control erst mal ausschalten so mal davon abgesehen das ist
nicht verkehrt das kann man durchaus ausschalten das ding ist nur intern bei mir erreichbar also
schon bestop beziehungsweise pb bei top nie habe ich nicht getestet das liegt aber hauptsächlich
daran weil das nicht in repos drinne ist wenn es in den repos drinne ist oder drinne wäre gucken
wir mal da könnte man das tatsächlich mal ausprobieren ansonsten hat man nichts davon wenn
es tolle neue software gibt gerade als gerade so system auslastungsgeschichten wenn man die nicht
auf remotesystem verwenden kann weil die nicht in den repos drin sind so fern sieht es auch aus
den mark und irgendwie hat er probleme mit unicode zeichen hier gerade mit wahrscheinlich
eine schriftart so fancy das ist solange ich das nicht am server verwenden kann das ist
irgendwie reichlich sinnlos weil meine lokale auslastung die guck ich mir sehr selten an was
für eine schrift haben muss ich installieren dass der kram funktioniert ich meine ich hab sogar ich
hab sogar eine ich hab sogar eine emoji schrift hat installiert dass ich morges im terminal habe also
nee und das andere habe ich auch noch nicht probiert aber das gibt es gar das gibt es zu
em user repos also wie gesagt solange es nicht in den repos bei großen distributionen dabei ist
finde ich bringt bringt diese tools alle nicht so schön schön sie sind aber wann will ich mir
denn mal meine lokale auslastung angucken ich will mir remotesystem auslastung und auch angucken
wenn die probleme haben so hat octopi fertig nee hat nicht fertig also wir disablen access
control übrigens nehmt das ernst was die hier schreiben sollte das wirklich irgendwie von
außen erreichbar sein dass auf gar keinen fall ausschalten weil sonst hat jeder aus dem internet
zugriff auf euren 3d drucke also nicht nur schlimm genug dass der zugriff auf eine linux kiste dann
quasi hat von euch und damit auch schon genug anstellen kann er hat auch zugriff auf euren
3d drucke im zweifelsfall fackelt noch irgendwer aus dem internet raus aus irgendwelche krassen
hexo aus bangladesh fragt mich also macht das auf gar keinen fall bei mir ist das kein problem
meine kiste ist nicht im mitteil erreichbar das in eine wir wollen nichts keine keine datentracken
connectivity check kann er machen blacklist das machen wir an das war wenn ich mich recht
erinnere für irgendwelche plugins die probleme machen dass er die erst gar nicht anzeigt so und
jetzt muss man drucke einrichten und zwar ich habe ein any q ich kann es wir machen wir machen
google auto vervollständigung any cubic i3 mega s jetzt muss man einstellen was das ding für
abmaße hat das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht deswegen muss ich nachgucken gibt es auch hier
bestimmt irgendwelche anleitungen also was muss man hier einstellen 210 210 205
205 210 210 21 zentimeter 210 210 der soll unten links anfangen heat bed heat chamber
eigentlich gut aus axen stellt der hier ein 6000 600 3 das ist default durchmesser von da wo das
3d druckzeug rauskommt vier millimeter das passt glaube ich passt das ja 0,4 und ein extruder wo
ich bis heute nicht genau weiß was der extruder ist ex ja ja finish reload excellent ist der
e3 oder e3 mega das gleiche von den maßen ja soweit ich weiß schon der mega s hat ein paar
kleine upgrades die man aber auch ziemlich einfach an dem e3 mega nachrüsten kann so update available
update na ja mach ma mach ma updates passt schon dass man wenigstens jetzt einmal auf dem aktuellen
stand sind in der zwischenzeit schalten wir mal die kamera ein und beim ist für die die
müssen wahrscheinlich gar nicht einschalten das macht er wahrscheinlich selbst gucken wir
mal ob die kamera geht klar wenn er das planen wenn er die abtätten zählen wir gucken gleich
ob die kamera geht vielleicht muss ich gar nichts gar nicht großartiges einstellen dass die kamera
funktioniert monka lieg ja ihr seht dann den 3d drucker in der abstellkammer war wahnsinn
klassisch huge high octane lieg macht er da drei stunden ab jetzt aber ist das noch payson 2
haben die forderst zu upgraden oh hier guckt mal da ach da geht es um plugins ok jetzt sind
anscheinend auch so eine mischung aus die sind wahrscheinlich so eine mischung aus
payson 2 und payson 3 was man da wohl alles sieht in der abstellkammer spülmittel haarwaschmittel
staubsauger aber das sieht man gar nicht dass man sieht in oder den 3d drucker wenn ich das
recht eingestellt habe reload so jetzt gucken wir mal ob die webcam funktioniert
triangulieren wandschein hat der abstellkammer eine position aber was ich schon alles geleakt
habe hier meine hofeinfahrt ja mann sonst was so da sind wir ok control mal gucken ob die webcam
geht es könnte sein dass die webcam geht aber ich das licht nicht an habe ich muss mal gucken ob
ich das licht angemacht habe in der abstellkammer
da da sehen wir guckt mal da da kann ich das licht sogar remote ein ausschalten aber gerade
nicht das kann ich nicht ein ausschalten das hat kein celly die abstell normalerweise brauche
ich aber ich werde das ihr also ihr werdet gleich sehen ich brauche das licht gar nicht
wirklich mein 3d drucker hat hier unten ein licht dran wir werden gleich sehen wenn man den demo
druck machen wir müssen das ding noch ordentlich leveln weil das bett ist total verstellt das ist
kacke als erstes installieren wir noch mal ein plugin und zwar installieren wir was mein plugin
manager get more installieren hier webcam fullscreen man kann sieht man nämlich ein
bisschen mehr von der webcam luten und leveln das ist ja ja luten je nachdem also manchmal geht
der druck echt in die hose an mit leveln ist gemeint dass das druck bett gerade eingestellt
wird so restart now ok wir haben plugins live wir müssen restarten warum auch immer das notwendig
ist aber wahrscheinlich einfach nur um auf nummer sicher zu gehen dass es funktioniert
nee wie gesagt kein celly in der abstellkammer aber ich brauche da auch kein celly in der
abstellkammer baue ich aber wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein ich habe noch genug weil eigentlich will
ich da gar kein licht also ich habe nämlich was die webcam anbelangt mehrere möglichkeiten
entweder mache ich da eine richtige kamera mit night vision hin ich habe nämlich noch
eine am start ach ich habe sogar erzählt ich habe mir fünf fünf kameras gekauft neue bei amazon
aber bevor jetzt wieder irgendjemand ankommt und sagt max schmeißt das geld nicht so zum
fenster raus die behalte ich nicht alle es ist nur unglaublich schwierig rauszukriegen was welche
kamera kann gerade von den chinesen weil da kaum was gescheites beisteht ich habe mir ich
habe mir ein paar kameras bestellt ich habe mir hier die bestellt die hat aber kein wladen das
weiß ich aber die ziemlich gute night vision und die ist ziemlich klein vielleicht verwende ich
die nämlich für den 3d drucker celly ist in den relay für unter putz relay da kannst du
licht mit einem ausschalten und der strom unter und der lichtschalter funktioniert weiterhin so
also ich habe mir die kamera gekauft dann habe ich mir eine habe ich vorher nicht mal gewusst
dass dieser hersteller überhaupt existiert richtig billiges kackding ob das ding irgendwo
bestellt das so richtig mega schlecht dann habe ich noch eine die bestellt und da bin ich mal
gespannt das werden wir uns nämlich im stream zusammen angucken die hat nämlich eine custom
firmen wir dann nämlich eine custom firmen wir für die hier hallo kio kunn kuck für die für
die china cam hier gibt es eine custom firmen wir die probieren wir dann demnächst im stream
aus das ding hatte ich mir bestellt das da das da und dann noch die zwei und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was davon was taugt das wichtige bei kameras bei mir ist ich habe da ein paar ansprüche
dran die finde ich nicht so hoch sind aber irgendwie schwierig schwierig sind was ich
gar nicht so genau versteht also ich möchte kamerakonfig über den web interface ich will
keine china app verwenden dass die kamera brauchen web interface auch initial konfig über den web
interface so das nächste ist ich brauche eine rtsp stream am besten in rtsp stream mit 720p plus
und ein in low quali schon mal die insta kameras angeschaut ja viel zu fett und viel zu alt von dem
was drin ist und viel zu teuer für das finde ich hat mir jetzt nicht so zugesagt und am liebsten
das ganze über wlan da war nämlich da bin ich auf twitter leute da bin ich wieder ausgeflippt
innerlich als die leute wieder nicht gecheckt haben und für drin reicht keine kamera mit
ein raspberry pi doch aber die ist auch nicht für drin ist ja für außen guck da outdoor outdoor
regen für innen würde eine raspberry pi kamera reichen aber für innen habe ich ja noch meine
ollen weiß cams mit custom firmen die gehen ja wunderbar also hier das war wo habe ich das
gepostet mit der kamera also ich habe gestern gesehen ich suche ein wlan outdoor überwachungs
kamera strom über usb oder 12 volt mindestens 720p stream über rtsp und web interface für
die config pan tilt wäre auch nicht verkehrt gut hat davon jetzt keiner muss aber auch nicht
unbedingt sein so und was antworten die leute drauf ok das ist gut also die antwort waren nicht alle
schlecht ja die meisten waren sogar gut habe ich mir eine bestellt erste antwort ist hier
irgendwas mit dass sie keinen wlan hat so das habe ich gegoogelt das ist mega fett das ding so
und das ist auch geil das das finde ich immer geil dass wenn du was auf twitter postest du
hast immer so belehrungsleute am start das vierte wort passt nicht mit dem sechsten wort zusammen
was weiß ich denn was das vierte und das sechste wort ist wieso wlan wenn lan viel besser und
stabiler ist außerdem würde das nur unnötig dein wlan traffic zumüllen außerdem stichwort
poe ok da möchte sich einer wahnsinnig schlau vorkommen als wäre ich nicht selbst auf die idee
gekommen die kamera über poe zu betreiben natürlich bin ich auf die idee gekommen die
kamera über poe zu betreiben das ist das erste was einem einfällt die sache ist nur die dass die
stelle an die die kamera kommt kein netzwerkabel hat da ist kein netzwerkabel so wechsel genau da
ist halt kein netzwerkabel was soll ich denn machen soll ich soll ich soll ich poe über luft machen
oder wie wenn er netzwerkabel wäre würde ich poe machen aber da ist kein netzwerkabel ist nicht
mal not even close netzwerkabel ja erstmal löcher in die wand machen fürs netzwerkabel
so ist der jetzt fertig ah ja gut wir haben es geschafft mal neu starten jetzt sollte
ich nämlich ah guck mal jetzt kann ich die webcam groß machen so und bei der gelegenheit
kann ich auch den drucker gleich mich mal zum drucker connecten und gucken ob das funktioniert
wir gucken nicht hin leute wenn wir nicht hingucken geht schneller postchamp
ist ist ist connected gut weil jetzt kann man auch hier ein bisschen mit rumfahren guck jetzt
fahren wir den mal ein bisschen rum oder so oder da fährt er oder klebt noch ein druck dran und
da liegt noch eine ssd öle die habe ich verwendet zum camera scharf stellen so einmal rumfahren und
jetzt kann man sagen fahrt zu home fahrt zu home und dann fährt er zu home so
wunderbar ich muss mal kurz rüber den graf abkratzen der da drauf hängt
hat gelevelt und festgestellt das bett ist total verzogen so fahre ich fahre ich nochmal
hier vor und jetzt sieht man auch ich habe da was vergessen abzumachen
ich habe da was vergessen abzumachen moment
oh nein habe ich die hand gelegt
hand lieg meine güte
so ok jetzt habe ich den ganzen kram hier mal abgekratzt übrigens das stößt hier oben nicht
an das hängt da drüber da passiert nichts guckt wenn ich voll hoch fahre das sieht zwar so aus
als stößt er aber das macht nichts aber das muss da also diese auflage sollte da auf jeden fall
weg aber da passiert nix so kann man das hier nämlich groß machen wunderbar so was wir jetzt
machen müssen bevor wir einen testdruck fahren ist wir müssen die auflösung bis sie hochstellen
weil die auflösung von der kamera sagt ein bisschen und wir können auch mal wie genau kann
das ding drucken was meinst du du meinst du genau mit irgendwas mit millimeter oder meinst du mit
genau wie ist wie ein 3d drucker funktioniert also ich werde gleich einen druck machen da gucken wir
zu aber millimeter also die öffnung da vorne ist 0,4 ich nicht genau das ist weil ich nicht
also für mein zeug mit bisschen gehäuse trocke genug also zumindest warte ich gerade mal wieder
rum wir müssen erst mal gucken dass die kamera ein bisschen höhere auflösung guckt weil ich
meine das sieht kacke aus und vielleicht können wir die exposure time auch ein bisschen hochstellen
dass das licht ein bisschen heller wird aber ihr werdet gleich sehen wenn das ding anfängt zu
drucken wird es hell da kann ich sogar das licht ausmachen deswegen ich habe den drucker gemoddet
von der weile schon mit einem licht ich habe irgendwas von aliens getwittert
in irgendwas mit aliens habe ich getwittert drucker
da ufo habe ich geschrieben so sieht das eigentlich habe hier am 3d drucker unten so
ein led ring dran dass das die sache schön schön hell macht leider ist der ring ein
bisschen zu hell so dass es spiegel an der platte unten drunter und ein das ist keine
klo schüssel in klein ich hier ausgedruckt habe gut jetzt stellen wir erst mal die kamera
ein bisschen hoch das ist ein bisschen moment steht in der boot konfig steht da steht da auch
mal ein wlan drin
also was man machen kann ist da hat ihr standardmäßig 10 fps als option 10 fps für
eine drucker drucker kamera ist ok aber man kann die auflösung bisschen hochstellen dazu
müssen wir uns aber was ihr wer macht denn sowas habt ihr es gesehen leute wer macht denn
sowas das ist ja das ist ja nahezu gotteslästerung wer hat es erkannt ok wahrscheinlich ist kein
auffall aber das hat die fault mäßig maus maussupport im wimm wer macht denn standardmäßig
wimm maussupport an set maus erstmal maussupport weg da kann man das irgendwie ordentlich bedienen
ja maussupport in wimm ist kacke da kannst du nichts kopieren und nichts anklicken im
terminal dann markiert das im wimm und das bringt dir überhaupt nichts so hier stehen
irgendwelche options die man benutzen kann also wir wollen die auflösung höher stellen
das heißt raspberry cam frame rate ist 10 das ist ok also minus x 720 1080 und y nein
was mache ich denn für ein scheiß x ist 280 nein doch warte mal x y nee y ist 1280 und
x ist 720 nee oder warte mal wie rum ist es jetzt warte mal nee warte mal x ist weite
ist nee 100 so rum 720 so rum ist richtig ok so was können wir sonst auch schön einstellen
exposure mode nacht ok br wir machen mal br die kamera sackt ein bisschen die ich da dran
habe wir machen mal wir machen mal die brightness ein bisschen höher auf 55 das ist ein bisschen
mehr als die fault ich glaube die fault ist 50 oder so so und jetzt ist die frage ob wir
exposure ein bisschen hoch stellen können dass das mehr licht abkriegt pro bild die
sache ist aber die ich glaube da kriegen wir keine 10 fps mehr hin ex auto ok das sollte
eigentlich nix machen das sollte eigentlich die fault sein dass das auto ist z awb mode
was ist denn awb mode ok nix nix für uns z image effect kann man nicht den sensor setzen
sensor mode das wäre eigentlich viel wichtiger dass man den sensor mode setzen kann da kann
man zum beispiel sagen ob man eher mehr fps will und dafür kleinere auflösung und sonst
was na gut wir probieren jetzt erstmal so aus ob das funktioniert ob das bild jetzt
besser aus sieht auf jeden fall besser aus wegen der auflösung und übrigens man muss
neu starten dass das greift das ist eine wichtige sache die man nicht vergessen darf was mich
das letzte mal mega gebatet hat man muss hier oben man darf kamera nicht auf auto stehen
lassen man muss die kamera auf die raspberry pi cam umstellen obwohl er die raspberry
pay automatisch erkennt aber wenn man die kamera nicht hardcoded auf die raspberry
pi cam umstellen dann greift die option hier unten nicht reboot was auch immer das für
eine logik ist quality können wir hoch machen also ich finde es viel interessanter wie man
den den sensor mode einstellen kann weil die kammer die pike haben verschiedene die haben
ja genau die haben verschiedene settings die kannst du einstellen auf full hd desa da
hast du diese frame rates die kannst du das einstellen da hast du 4 zu 3 diese frame rates
also den sensor mode müsste man angeben können das wäre eigentlich das allerwichtigste
dabei weil das default sensor mode meistens übelster crap ist für das was man machen
will na gut gucken wir mal sind wir wieder da wir sind wieder da jetzt müssen wir erstmal
noch eins machen ssh copy id dann müssen wir nämlich noch einmal unser passport eingeben
ab jetzt können wir uns ohne passport einloggen so schauen wir mal ob die webcam auflösung
jetzt besser ist ja
was passiert da gerade
bewegt sich der drocker oder bewegt sich die kamera
warum bewegt er sich
monkaS vielleicht fällt auch die kamera gleich ab ja hallo ah ich will das jetzt zumachen
du got act gleich kommt der jumpscare
ich weiß nicht genau was das da macht
ok ich ich richte ich richte mal kurz die ich richte mal kurz die kamera wieder ein
bisschen aus kann es sein dass es leckt als fack
das mega leckt
das leckt mega komm ich jetzt mal an soviel quali näh das ist ja das kann eigentlich
nicht sein hier mein wir haben ja fast nix an quali da gemacht
es liegt an ex auto der sebaro der sebaro hat es kaputt gemacht ich sage es liegt an
ex auto
so ich starte mal neu jetzt gehts bestimmt ein klein flüssiger ich mach mal die kamera
fest
konnte ja nur wirklich keiner wissen jetzt. Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Oh, guck mal, ich hab mir das Licht ausgemacht. Man sieht aber, dass die Kamera an ist,
weil man sieht das Display vom 3D-Trocker. So, ja die Kamera ist nicht so wirklich richtig gut,
richtig gut fest. So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt genauso viel laggt noch.
Also, wirklich flüssig ist das net. Ich hätte jetzt aber eigentlich erwartet,
dass es flüssiger ist. Ich würde jetzt auch erwarten, dass es jetzt runterfährt. Oh mein,
da macht ja fast gar nichts. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Kamera laggt, da macht einfach nichts.
Wisst ihr was, wir lassen jetzt einfach mal was drucken. Nein, doch die Kamera laggt ein
bisschen. Die Kamera laggt ein bisschen, guck mal, so eine Sekunde, oder fünf Sekunden. Warum laggt?
Das ist aber ganz schön lang. Also, so lang sollte das eigentlich nicht sein. Man schaut mal,
das sind fünf Sekunden lag. Warum laggt das so lang? Viel zu lang, haben wir doch irgendeinen
Mist angegeben. Da kannst du ja gar nicht richtig zugucken. Gut, beim 3D-Drucken an sich ist das
ziemlich wurscht. Der macht sie fünf Sekunden nicht aus. Nö, aber ansonsten kann er eigentlich nicht viel sein.
Vielleicht ist die Auflösung jetzt so hoch. Komm mal, also weiter, klick. Fünf Sekunden. Na gut,
wir installieren noch ein anderes Plugin. Ich will nämlich dieses Sidebar-Plugin installieren,
wo man die Kamera an der Seite sieht. Das da. So, und danach machen wir mal so einen Calibration-Druck.
Wir können mal gucken, wie viel der MJPEG-Streamer braucht, aber, äh, hältst schon Grenzen. Ich starte
now. Nee, zehn FPS müsste eigentlich relativ flüssig sein. Dass es so eine Verzögerung hat,
ist merkwürdig. Also fünf Sekunden ist ganz schön viel. Ich werde das in Zukunft aber eh
nicht so machen. Ich werde die Webcam weiter ganz normal per WebRTC in meinen Überwachungskamera
Frontend packen und dann ist es auch schnell. Aber es ist halt praktisch, wenn man die Webcam
hier drinne hat, dann kann man nämlich hier direkt während man Settings macht zugucken.
So, Reload. Weil jetzt haben wir nämlich hier oben auch noch Webcam, das ist relativ nützlich.
Weil sonst müsste man immer immer in Control sein. Gut, also wir 3D-drucken mal was. Wir 3D-drucken
mal dieses Calibration-Ding, was ich vorher auch gedruckt habe. Und da sieht man nämlich hinten,
wie schlecht. What the fuck? Noch unterschiedlich schnell der Kram. So, da wird man zumindest mal
sehen, wie schlecht das Bett vom 3D-Drucker ausgerichtet ist. By the way, der ist doch
verkehrt. Wie ist das? Ach nee, er ist rechts oben. Okay, nee, das passt. Okay, also, wir nehmen das
Ding hier. Das habe ich nämlich das letzte Mal auch genommen. Genau, das Druck, das Druck zur
kleine Quadrate auf das Druckbett. Da kann man dann erkennen, ob man sein Druckbett richtig
ausgerichtet hat. Also sprich, hier unten drunter, also das da. Ich versuche es jetzt mal hoch zu
fahren, was mit Lack gar nicht so einfach ist. Ja, ja, sehr gut. Das Ding hier, wenn das nicht
gerade, das leckt aber huge, Alter. So krass am lecken. Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir probieren
das mal aus. Stellen das jetzt noch mal kurz zurück auf default. Gucken, ob das daran irgendwie
was mit zu tun hat. Ja, die Vorschau ist auch noch schneller gewesen. Ist komisch,
ne? So, wir starten mal neu. Ich lad mir mal das Kalibrierungsding runter. Genau, also Sinn und
Zweck der Sache ist, dass man das Muster schön sieht und dass nichts zu dick bzw. nichts zu dünn
ist. Also sprich, dass der Druckkopf nicht schleift und dass das Muster keine Lücken hat. Und dann
ist es gut. Und dann werdet ihr mal sehen, wie schlecht mein Bett eingestellt ist. Ihr habt es
ja vorhin schon kurz gesehen. Thingiverse, wer es nicht kennt, ist übrigens eine super Seite für
3D-Drucker-Fans. Also da findet man zu allen möglichen Sachen fertige Gehäuse, fertige
Projekte, sonst was. Das hier ist eigentlich ganz nützlich zum Kalibrieren. Zumindest habe ich
das letztes Mal auch mitgemacht. Was? Ich soll mein... Ernsthaft? Warum soll ich mein Werb... Gut,
da gucken wir uns die Werbung von denen an. Okay. Nach 5 Stunden konnte ich wie ein gebürtiger
Brite sprechen. Ah, das ist auch noch äußerst seriöse Werbung. Alles klar. Nach 5 Stunden,
perfekt Englisch, Native. Alles klar, natürlich. Was sonst? So, jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal noch
ein Programm installieren, mit dem man die ganzen Sachen für einen 3D-Drucker aufbereiten kann.
Weil es ist so, ein 3D-Drucker, der kann nur quasi Anweisungen für seinen Druckkopf umsetzen.
Ein 3D-Drucker hat keine Ahnung von irgendwelchen 3D-Models oder sowas. Dementsprechend braucht man
erst ein Programm, was aus den 3D-Models Anweisungen für den 3D-Drucker macht. Und das machen wir hiermit.
Und es gibt auch ein Plugin, dass man das direkt mit Octopi verbinden kann,
direkt hier aus dem Slicer rausdrucken kann. So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal unsere Drucke
hinzufügen. Den da, jawoll, next, finish, gut. So, jetzt öffnen wir den Kram wieder runter.
Ich hab echt, ich hab irgendwelche Schriftdaten nicht installiert. Das sieht ja grausam aus.
Paper, please. Wo hab ich's runtergeladen? Wohin hab ich das runtergeladen? Max Downloads. So,
alles, alles gut. Max Downloads. Hä? Wo ist mein Download? Achso, ich muss den Kram erstmal
entpacken. Ah. Was, hab ich kein Unzip installiert? Ernsthaft nicht? Ist ja nix drauf hier. Ist ja,
ist ja armselig. So, jetzt aber. Files, da ist es. Gut. So, huge 3D-Model, ich weiß. 5 kleine
Quadrate. So, und jetzt sagt mir hier, jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, dass wir die Dicke
und so richtig eingestellt haben. 02, das, sorry, das passt alles. Alles gut. Slice. So,
und da kommen jetzt die Daten raus, die man zum 3D-Drucker schicken kann. Speichern wir das
Ganze, gehen wir in Octoprint. Und das ist jetzt halt der riesen Vorteil, wenn man Octoprint verwendet.
Normalerweise müsste man den Kram jetzt auf die, ähm, eine SD-Karte packen, zum 3D-Drucker laufen,
eine SD-Karte reinschieben und drucken. Und dann würde man, dann hätte man überhaupt keine
Übersicht. So, was man jetzt machen kann ist, den Kram, warum muss ich eigentlich alles 5 mal
machen gerade? So, jetzt kann man nämlich den Kram hier hochladen, dann erkennt er das,
dann kann man das anklicken und dann sagt er, ok, ich brauch, achso, erstmal muss ich mich
connecten zum Drucker. Ja, stimmt, Drang-Drop geht, hab ich nicht dran gedacht. Ja. Wie gesagt, ich hab
leider nichts mehr gedruckt. So, dann klickt man das an, wenn er irgendwann mal den Drucker
erkennt hat, 3 Stunden später. Ähm, manchmal fällt das übrigens und dann muss man es nochmal
machen und dann geht's. So eins von 20 mal geht das irgendwie kaputt. Dann muss man einfach
disconnecten und nochmal connecten, dann ist gut. Jetzt sollte er es aber langsam mal gecheckt haben,
dass er sich mit dem 3D-Drucker verbindet. Ansonsten, wenn er es nicht gecheckt hat,
machen wir die Windows-Taktik, wir rebooten einfach. Ah, jetzt hat er es gecheckt, ok,
ist verbunden. Ähm, und nu, achso, wir haben jetzt glaub ich auch wieder die
kleinere Auflösung hier, ne? Ist das jetzt schneller mit der kleineren Auflösung?
Äh, what the fuck ist mit dem? Was hat er mit der Druckerverbindung?
Was hat er für Schmerzen? Ey, ich hab jetzt die Tür zu. Normalerweise hört man,
wenn er sich verbindet, der macht dann dü-dü-dü. Ich starte jetzt mal den Raspberry Pi neu,
wenn das nichts hilft, dann äh, dann starte ich den 3D-Drucker neu.
Der für Schmerzen. Never happened before. Schauen wir mal, wann das Ding wieder da ist.
Ansonsten ist das zumindest die Verbindung eigentlich ziemlich zuverlässig. Klickste
drauf und es geht. Ist gut. Firefox, alles klar.
Mach es einfach ohne HTTPS. Gebaidet. You got gebaidet. Wer braucht HTTPS?
Echt, kann man das ausschalten? Das ist praktisch. So, ok,
mal gucken, ob es connecten jetzt funktioniert. Achtung. Der hat irgendeinen Schlag gerade.
Ah, jetzt hat er sich verbunden. Ok, mal gucken, ob es jetzt ein bisschen
lackfreier geht. Ah, guck mal. Oh, oh, Leute, die Kamera rutscht. Die Kamera ist übelst
und dumm oben hin gepappt. Ah, ich muss die Kamera festmachen.
Ja, das ist die Standard. Das Ding ist komplett Standard.
Alter, Kamera, fuck, wenn ich dich habe. Ich weiß schon, warum ich da meine Unify-Kamera
das nächste Mal hinhänge. Die bewegt sich wieder.
Ich klebe es gleich fest. Ok, wir hoffen jetzt mal einfach, dass es so bleibt.
Und wir starten mal an den Druck. Ok, die Kamera ist übrigens, by the way,
mittlerweile auch ein bisschen shabby. So, Druck, Druck. Zack. Er meint vier Minuten,
ich kann euch sagen, es wird ein bisschen länger dauern. Print. So, und was jetzt auch
in OctoPrint bzw. Octopi ganz nützlich ist, die Anzeige, du siehst, wann er anfängt
zu drucken. Also sprich, Target Temperature und Bad Temperature, also sprich, das ist
es dort, worauf er druckt, das ist die Temperatur vom Druckkopf. Und erst, wenn das oben ist,
fängt er halt an zu drucken. Deswegen ist allein schon die Printzeit hier immer übelst
gebait, das kann überhaupt nicht stimmen. Das dauert jetzt 1-2 Minuten zum aufheizen,
weshalb die Printtime schon mal gar nicht hinkommt. So, und jetzt könnt ihr gleich
sehen, wie schlecht mein Bett gelevelt ist. So, in 5 Stunden, wenn er aufgeheizt hat.
Ich glaube, da fängt er erstmal an und heizt das Druckbett auf und danach heizt er den
Druckkopf aus. Dass er das Druckbett aufheizt, ist so, ist wirklich praktisch, weil, wenn
der, wie nennt man es, dieses Filament, wenn das auf das Druckbett kommt und das Druckbett
ist warm, dann klebt das extrem fest. Wenn das Druckbett kalt ist, dann geht das ab.
Also, es heißt, solange das Druckbett warm ist, pappt die Unterlage richtig fest. Stimmt
die Printtime? Die Printtime hier stimmt nicht, aber es gibt nen Plugin, was ne deutlich bessere
Printtime-Berechnung hat. Die Standard-Printtime-Berechnung ist, naja. Stimmt mal, mal stimmts nicht.
Clocks HD ist das Auto-Level-Ding. Moin Patrick. Wir warten, bis der 3D-Drucker anfängt zu
machen. So, jetzt sollte eigentlich die Temperatur gleich hochgehen. Guckt ihr, zack. Jetzt geht
die Temperatur vom Druckkopf hoch und dann, ne, wie gesagt, auch die Printtime, wenn die
Temps stimmen, ist nicht so ganz richtig. Es gibt nen Plugin, was das deutlich besser
berechnet, die Printtime. Ah guck mal, habt ihr gesehen, das Licht ist angegangen. Das
ist das, was ich da mal dran gemoddet hatte. Ähm, wenn der Strom angeht, hier oben, hier
ist ja ein Lüfter drin. Und er macht den Lüfter an, ab ner gewissen Temperatur. Hier
so bei, keine Ahnung, bei 120 Grad. Bei 120 Grad geht der Lüfter an. Wenn der Lüfter
angeht, geht auch der LED-Ring an. Man sieht jetzt schon das Problem da dran, der LED-Ring
ist eigentlich viel viel zu hell. Da spiegelt es, fuck, das müsste ich in der ganze Ecke,
da müsste ich irgendwie noch irgendwas zum dimmen dran machen oder so. Aber das war das
erste, was ich mit dem 3D-Drucker damals gemacht hab. Ich hab mir den Teil 3D-Druckt, um meinen
3D-Drucker zu modden. Welchen Adretug hast du? Ein Anycubic E3 Mega S. Hab ich mir Anfang
letzten Jahres geholt und ich hab halt kaum was mit gedruckt und ich hab festgestellt,
dass der von vor einem halben Jahr oder so mein Oktopal schon abgekackt ist und ich
gar nichts mehr drucken konnte. Deswegen würde ich das jetzt gerade wieder neu installieren.
E3 Omega. E3 Monka S. So, und wenn der jetzt irgendwann mal die Temperatur erreicht hat,
was jetzt übrigens soweit ist, gleich, bei 200 Grad, eben 10, bei 200 Grad, legt der
los. So, gleich gehts los. Und da drückt der jetzt dieses Kalibrierungsding und dann seht
ihr, wie schlecht mein Bett gelevelt ist. Ah, auf gehts. Ups, auf gehts. Das ist, by
the way, das Kabel von der Kamera, glaub ich, oder? Das Kabel von der Kamera? Das wäre
nicht gut, wenn das Kabel von der Kamera da hängt. Das reißt gleich ab. Es bewegt sich.
So, jetzt spritzt er erstmal ne Runde drum herum, um, äh, Filament ein bisschen zu reinigen.
Das kann man übrigens ausstellen, dass der einmal den 3D Druck umfährt. Oder 2, 3, ich
glaube, der umfährt den 3D Druck sogar 2, 3 mal. Das ist einfach, dass da die Düse
gereinigt ist. Aber der Strahler ist doch ganz nützlich, ne? Man erkennt sogar ein
bisschen mehr jetzt, wenn das da dran strahlt. Obwohl es halt viel zu hell ist. So, jetzt
ist er, jetzt hat er 3 Mal drum herum gesprayt. Und jetzt fängt er klar an. Eigentlich voll
die Materialverschwendung bei solcher Strecke. So, jetzt fängt er an. So, und er macht nichts
anderes, wie 5 kleine Quadrate drucken. Und die kann man sich danach angucken und daran
sieht man, äh, wie gut das Bett gelevelt ist. Und ihr werdet sehen, das ist ganz, ganz
grausam gelevelt bei mir. Also im Optimalfall sollte das Ganze so aussehen am Ende. So
sollten die Quadrate aussehen. Man hat noch ein bisschen Muster drauf. Bei mir sind die
Quadrate eher, eher teils so aus und teils so. Also, ihr werdet es gleich sehen. Mal
kurz fullscreen. Der war jetzt lustig, ich finde, dass die Vorschau hier mehr ruckelt
als die andere Vorschau. Sehr merkwürdig. Guck mal hier. Das hängt, das hängt schon
voll in Fetzen hier oben. Seht ihr das? Das hängt schon voll in Fetzen. Das sieht eher
so aus hier anstatt so. Also da ist der Abstand zu groß. In der Mitte ist es, in der Mitte
ist gut. Ups. In der Mitte, in der Mitte ist ganz gut. Was ist das für ein blauer
Balken? Ich glaube, das ist der Druckfortschritt, wie weit er ist. Der denkt, er ist gleich
fertig, aber das ist G-Bait. Der muss noch zwei Stück drucken. Aber im Gegensatz zu
ungefähr kommt es hin. Der ist auch viel zu. Wobei, das könnte, der rechts unten könnte
ganz gut sein. Und man sieht, der Strahler ist viel zu hell, wenn er zu nah dran ist.
Da siehst du nichts. So und jetzt müsst ihr noch hochfahren, noch einen Dreieck, äh
noch einen Vier-Eck machen. Und dann kann man sich den Kram mal angucken. Blup. Guckt
hier, hier siehst du schon richtig die Lücken drinnen. Also das ist nichts. Das Bett muss
ich morgen mal in Ruhe noch einstellen. Das ist übrigens auch ein Vorteil, wenn man sich
einen teureren 3D-Drucker kauft. Die machen das automatisch. Oder zumindest automatisch
den Abstand messen. Dass das das auskleicht. Ich muss hier gucken, hier unten sind so Rädchen
dran. Ich kann hier unten an den Rädchen drehen und halt einstellen, dass das Bett
gerade ist. Ja, so jetzt müsste er fertig sein angeblich. Guck mal, der ist sogar fertig,
das war relativ akkurat. Das hier war viel zu nah dran, das in der Mitte ist glaube
ich ganz okay. So, fertig gedruckt. Ne, ich will da nichts moden, großartig. So und jetzt
geht er gleich wieder aus, sobald die Temperatur runtergegangen ist. Also die Temperatur fällt
jetzt. Aktuell kann ich das gar nicht abmachen. Also das ist so bombenfest, hängt das noch
hier unten an der Unterlage dran. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich muss jetzt erstmal warten bis das
abgekühlt ist, sonst kann ich es nicht abmachen. Also das ist nicht mal flüssig, ne. Also
das ist sofort hart, sobald das da drauf ist. Aber es klebt hart as fuck an der Unterlage
und erst wenn das hier wieder runterfällt, so auf keine Ahnung, 30 Grad oder so, erst
dann kriegt man das überhaupt von der Unterlage ab. Bis jetzt kannst du das knicken. Genau,
jetzt wo der grad hier am ausgehen ist, ein anderes Plugin, was ich unbedingt noch ausprobieren
wollte, ist das hier. Print Time Genius. Der ist wohl deutlich genauer, was Druckzeitenberechnen
anbelangt. Übrigens, wer sich fragt, wie lange es dauert, was richtiges zu drucken,
wir probieren das jetzt mal kurz aus. So ungefähr, weil hier der hat auch ne ungefähr Vorschau,
wie lange das ganze dauert. Und zwar, wenn ich mir jetzt mal ein Gehäuse raussuche für
mein ESP32. Irgendwas, was passt. Übrigens, das ist das falsche. Das ist das richtige.
Oh, die Seite ist ja wieder massive high speed hier. So, wenn man jetzt irgendwie sowas
nimmt, was übrigens extrem hässlich bei dem ausgedruckt aussieht, aber ich glaube,
das ist ganz, ganz nett. Aber ich brauch ja das da oben, lass ich weg für die Antenne.
Dann nehmen wir zum Beispiel das Gehäuse, dann was mal runter, aber ich muss den Adblock
wieder ausmachen. Singiverse nervt. Weißt ihr mal aus dem Kopf, wie diese andere Seite
da hieß? Es gab noch eine zweite. Dies verlängert den Geschlechtsakt und steigert Erlebnisse.
Sie werden auch die anspruchsvollsten Frauen befriedigen können. Sehen. Nein. Nicht sehen.
Tonka Toss sehen. Höchst seriöse Werbung, für die ich hier mein Adblocker ausschalten
soll, wie es aussieht. Erinnert mich an den Fail damals. Da konnte ich ja nichts für.
My Mini Factory. War das das? Das könnte das tatsächlich gewesen sein. Bin ich mir nicht
sicher, ob es die Seite war, die ich mein. Zumindest wir öffnen das jetzt mal. Also
ich muss das mal anzippen. Anzip. Wir öffnen das mal, damit wir sehen, die. Was hat der
für Schmerzen? Anzip, Alter. Yes. Yes. Yes. Alles entpacken. So. Wir öffnen das ganze
jetzt mal. Und. Dann gucken wir mal. Übrigens, ich sollte es erst mal löschen. So. Warte.
Wir drucken das mal. Nur das nebeneinander drucken braucht meistens viel zu lang. Man
konnte doch irgendwie sagen, es ist ewig her, dass ich es gemacht habe. Man konnte irgendwie
sagen, dass er das ordentlich anordnen soll. Irgendwas nochmal. Ja, so. Genau, wenn man
jetzt sagt Slice, braucht der. Okay, das stimmt nicht ganz. Ich würde eher sagen, wenn man
auf 03 hochgeht, also sprich, dass er das Kröber druckt, ist er schneller. Aber es
ist halt nicht so nicht so fein. Also sprich, wenn ich das jetzt nehme und sage, okay, fang
mal an zu drucken. Infill braucht man hier nicht wirklich großartig, weil ich meine,
das ist halt nichts zum Infillen. Dann ist er jetzt der Meinung, er braucht 52. Was macht
ein Preview? Okay. So und ich würde mal sagen, 52 Minuten ist ein bisschen Chebat. Wir laden
das jetzt mal runter. Ups. Moment. New Project. Wir laden das mal runter und gucken dann,
was diese, dieses Analyse Ding sagt, wie lange es brauchen würde. 52 Minuten. Zag. Octoprint.
Restart now. Da will ich ja wirklich für alles neu starten. Ja, Clocks, aber ehrlich gesagt,
ich will das Ding nicht modden. Großartig. Ich habe mir den gekauft. Erstens, weil guter
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis und zweitens, weil der Out of the Box gut funktioniert. Hallo?
Ich will das Ding. Also 3D-Drucker ist eine Sache. Die habe ich mir für ein paar Gehäuse
gekauft. Naja, wenn du da eine größere, wenn du irgendwelche größeren Sachen dran schraubst
und sowas. Ich habe mir das gekauft, ein paar Gehäuse auszudrucken. Ich habe da gar kein
großer Interesse dran, da rumzubasteln. Wobei das ja auch schon wieder nicht richtig stimmt.
Aber ich habe ja auch diese LED-Ansicht vorne dran gemacht. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, laden
wir mal hoch und gucken, was er meint, was das braucht. So, übrigens, man kann hier analysieren
lassen, wie lange er der Meinung ist, dass das braucht. Da muss man irgendwie das Plugin
hier print time genus analyze. Und jetzt? Äh, ne warte mal, wo steht da Kram jetzt noch
mal? Ne, äh, bin verwirrt. Estimated print time 433. Ach so, ja.
Ja, aber wobei die print time berechnen, sollte eigentlich auch so funktionieren. So, ist wieder
verbunden. Sollte, oder ist das schon die, ist das schon die Analyse von diesem Plugin?
Ähm, das kann natürlich auch sein. Ich weiß nicht, wir gucken, wir probieren das jetzt
mal aus. Also, Upload. Ähm, hier, das neue Teil. Analysieren. Ich glaube, der möchte
mir sagen, dass er das analysiert hat, aber, äh, das irgendwie habe ich, irgendwie habe
ich nicht alle Schriften aninstalliert. 54 Minuten, okay. So, gehen wir mal in das Plugin
und lassen hier nochmal analysieren. What the fuck? A fail. Okay, das war immer safe.
So. Er meint, er braucht 54 Minuten. Na dann, print. Let's go. Let's go, Printe. Oh, oh,
Moment. Ich muss das alte abkratzen. Ah, ah, Pause, Pause. Cancel. Ah. Moment, ich will
abbrechen. Abrechen? Hallo? Ab, lass mich abbrechen. Okay. Ich darf nicht abbrechen.
Abbrechen ist nicht erlaubt. Smoke, Smoke. Gut, es kann ja nicht wirklich was passieren.
Also, ich habe jetzt Pause gedrückt, ist das schön und gut, aber ich will, ich will
cancelen. Lässt du mich cancelen? Ist wie beim 2D Drucker. Ah, ja, okay, cancel. Okay,
ich kratze das, ich kratze, nee, jetzt kann ich das alte nicht abkratzen, weil das Bett
so warm ist. Okay, jetzt muss ich erstmal warten, bis das Bett wieder runtergefahren
ist. Na toll. Vielleicht kriege ich, vielleicht kriege ich die Kamera auch noch besser dran
gepappt. Auf der anderen Seite, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn ich das jetzt drucke, oder?
Ich meine, das Bett ist so dermaßen shab. Das sollte ich erstmal richtig einstellen,
bevor ich mir da jetzt irgendwelche Gehäuse drucke. Felix sagt Hallo, vier Monate, Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription. Huge. Um nicht zu sagen Massive Subscription. Warte ich jetzt
mal, bis das Druckbett abgekühlt ist. Ja, aber Octoprint ist eine sehr praktische Software,
ich könnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, ich muss mal gucken, was mir für eine Schrift
da anfällt, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Windows-Fonts,
garantiert irgendwelche Windows-Fonts. Bestimmt, bestimmt irgendwelche, irgendwelche MS-Fonts,
das brauchen wir jetzt, brauche ich bestimmt. Oh, MS-Fonts, dann das, guck mal hier, diesen
ganzen ganzen Windows-Crap. Gehe mal davon aus, dass das irgendwie, ich weiß keine Ahnung,
was das für Zeichen sind, was der da für Schmerzen hat, warum die nicht gehen, zumindest
fehlt mir auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Schriften an. Ansonsten müssen wir jetzt wegen jedem
Mist zum 3D-Drucker rüberrennen und eine SD-Karte reinschieben, was total beknackt
ist noch. Ok, schauen wir mal, ob es das war. Firefox, Hallo, Restore. Ah, nein. Ok, was,
was könnte mir, was könnten mir für Fonts fehlen? Ich meine, ich kann fucking Emojis
anzeigen lassen in der, in der Kommando-Zeile, was könnte mir für Fonts fehlen, dass er
das nicht anzeigen muss? Ist das überhaupt für ein Zeichen? Ich, das denn, was das ist.
Ist das irgendwo, oh mein, wo ist das überhaupt? Vielleicht ist auch das Encoding von der Seite
im Arsch. Das, das ist, da steht da eben ein paar JavaScript oder so drin. Was ist das
für Zeichen, die er nicht mag? Wir gucken mal, was man Browser anzeigen kann. UTF-8
Browser Testpage. Jawoll. Wie, wenn ich? What the fuck? Wie kriegst du jetzt raus, was
das für ein Zeichen ist? Aha, ja. Star-Symbol. Black Star-Symbol. Duty-Code 1.1 von Missing.
Lennox. Brauche ich da für einen Font, äh. Ancient Fonts.
Duty sind nicht schlecht. Ah. Excellent. Yes. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Moin, Flo690. Mal gucken, ob ich mir das jetzt anzeigen lassen darf. Ah. Guck mal da, ein
Stern. Der Font hat also gefehlt, ok. Ja, sieht doch gleich viel besser aus. Das ist,
das ist sozusagen, dass man sich um so ein Kram überhaupt kümmern muss. Auf der anderen
Seite, ja gut. Äh. Wer soll es installieren, wenn nicht ich? Ja. So. Also es hat keinen
Sinn, wenn ich das andere Ding jetzt drucke. Ich mein, das, also erstens muss ich den Kram
noch abkratzen und zweitens muss ich erstmal das Bett richtig ausrichten, dass das sinnvoll
ist. Aber, dass es wirklich gut reagieren tut, ist nett, oder? Das ist alles ein bisschen
umgefuddelt. Naja, gut. Ähm. Zumindest an sich tut der Kram wieder. Bin ich schon mal
ganz froh, dass das wieder, dass das prinzipiell wieder geht. Ähm. Da kann ich morgen ein
bisschen bett leveln und gucken, dass der Kram hier wieder ordentlich gerade ist. Und
dann drucke ich mir mal ein paar Gehäuse. So chat, gibt es noch irgendwelche wichtigen
Sachen, die? Ganz wichtig, dass mir das Windows Defender mitteilt. Unglaublich wichtig. Es
wäre eigentlich am besten, wenn Windows Defender die Klappe halten würde und mich benachrichtigen
würde, wenn was gefährliches gefunden wurde. Würde man eigentlich vorausgehen, dass das
reicht. Aber nicht so unter Windows. So Leute, 21.12. Mal gucken, ob ich morgen am Start
bin. Mal gucken, wie gesagt, spätestens Sonntag, Aufwachstream. Ähm. War heute vielleicht
nicht für jeden was, aber ich hoffe, es hat euch trotzdem gefallen. Und, ja, gibt es
sonst noch irgendwas wichtiges? Trinkst du Alkohol? Nein. Ich habe ein super Ding zum
3D-Drucken gefunden. Ist das ein Glas oder was? Zeig mal her. Was ist denn das? Ups,
ich habe gerade außerdem mal ein Chat zugemacht. Chat, falls ihr was geschrieben habt, ich
habe es nicht gesehen. Was soll denn das sein? Was ist das? Ihr kennt das überhaupt nicht.
Da schüttelt man oben rein und dann verteilt es das in alle Gläser. Aha. Also quasi exquisite.
Ja, sowas kann man 3D-Drucken. Warum nicht? Was ich demnächst nochmal 3D-Drucken will
ist ein Sieb für unsere Regenrinne. Aber nicht die große Regenrinne am Haus, sondern
die kleine Regenrinne über dem Terrassendach. Da ist so eine Mini-Regenrinne oder so ein
Mini-Abguss und Ausfluss, Abfluss, wie auch immer. Und da habe ich aktuell einen Schneebesen
reingesteckt, dass es ein bisschen gefiltert ist. Und da wollte ich mir so einen Siebfilter
ausdrucken. Muss ich mal ausmessen und gucken, dass es da gut hinpasst. Also wir sehen uns.
Bis am spätesten, bis am Sonntag. Machts gut, bis denn. See you.